[Música]
conoces a alguien que nunca se haya
tomado unas el fin o mejor dicho cuántas
self y se han tomado desde que llegaron
a este auditorio y las tuvieron ya sus
redes sociales
el problema no es que sea una podemos
ver desde la monalisa que les aclaro no
soy de esos tiempos
hasta la entrega de los oscars con los
ricos y famosos en hollywood todos
tienen algo en común al igual que
nosotros y es que nos encantan tomarnos
el fis y colocarlas en nuestras redes
sociales y compartirlas con nuestros
amigos sin embargo el problema no es que
sea una el problema es cuando son muchas
dicen los expertos en salud mental que
la tendencia excesiva del self y es un
indicador de falta de autoestima vanidad
que se traduce en una construcción de la
identidad así que ahora el día de hoy yo
vengo a mencionarles ya compartir con
ustedes la otra cara de un self y y cómo
es que una representante de la
generación ni x como yo ha aprendido a
conocer y amar a esta generación que le
quita el sueño a muchos a muchos
mercadólogos educadores empleadores y
sobre todo a padres de familia
y no hay que decir más quiénes son son
los millennials actualmente ellos son el
50 por ciento de la población de nuestro
país y estoy segura que son más del 50
por ciento en este auditorio representan
170 millones de habitantes solamente en
latinoamérica y para el año 2025
dominarán el 75 por ciento de la fuerza
laboral a nivel global así que en otras
palabras los millennials nos están
invadiendo llegaron para quedarse están
cambiando el mundo y están cambiando la
forma de hacer política de consumir de
trabajar de educar y de relacionarse
un milenio por definición es aquella
persona que nació entre la década de los
años 80 y el año 2000 y llego a la edad
adulta con el cambio de siglo
en otras palabras estos jóvenes son los
primeros nativos digitales y dicho de
alguna manera ya nacieron con el dedo
torio sino enseñarle un celular o una
laptop a un bebé y lo primero que hace
es darle a la pantalla de tokio entre
muchas otras cosas hay algunas que los
caracterizan y que los investigadores
resaltan y es que están mejor preparados
pero tienen menores niveles de ingreso y
de empleo que las generaciones
anteriores tienen una gran necesidad de
reconocimiento y probablemente por eso
miden su nivel de aceptación en función
de los likes y de los fallos que
acumulan en sus redes sociales pasan
conectados 7 horas al día a través de
diferentes dispositivos en otras
palabras es casi un trabajo de tiempo
completo y no les pagan por eso
y otra de las otras de las
características también que podemos
destacar es que son adictivos para todos
cuentan con una para contar calorías
hacer ejercicio pedir un taxi pedir
comida programar su agenda cualquier
cosa que necesiten hacer hay una
disponible no digamos ya las apps de los
juegos así que en esta oportunidad
quiero compartirles lo que ha sido mi
experiencia trabajando en una
institución educativa durante los
últimos ocho años donde sus 25 mil
estudiantes y el 54% de los
colaboradores incluyendo un miembro del
comité ejecutivo forma parte de esta
generación del cf y es que al recorrer
los pasillos de la universidad he podido
constatar
y percibir muchas características que
sería injusto no mencionar las el día de
hoy
primero
son emprendedores por naturaleza de
acuerdo a nuestras encuestas al 54% al
40% perdón de nuestros estudiantes o
jóvenes no les interesa trabajar para
una multinacional o una gran corporación
sino que tienen como objetivo el
emprendimiento
y así los vemos trabajando proyectos muy
interesantes que en un futuro cercano
van a emprender son auténticos por
naturaleza y cuando hablo de
autenticidad se me viene a la mente mi
hijo carlos de 23 años
hace un par de años me llamo en la
universidad donde estudiaba y trabajaba
y me dijo más te tengo una buena y una
mala noticia inmediatamente me senté
porque sabía que era algo importante lo
que tenía que decirle y me comentó la
buena es que me ascendieron en el
trabajo yo casi que brincaba para
felicitarlo cuando me dijo la mala y la
mala es que no lo acepte y encima de
todo
mi jefa está enojada conmigo así que
cuando le pregunté cuál fue la razón me
dijo mamá tenía que venir vestido de
saco y corbata y yo no soy así no voy a
dejar mis tenis y mis camisetas
así que aquí pueden ver a carlos
pueden saber quién es por los tenis y
las bermudas el día de su graduación
cuando tuvo su título de licenciado en
marketing hoy trabaja en una prestigiosa
agencia de publicidad haciendo lo que
más le gusta en un mundo de creativos y
esto me deja una gran reflexión y es que
la vida es demasiado corta como para
desperdiciarla en algo que no somos o
que no nos haga feliz
otra de sus características son
positivos pro positivos y siempre creen
que lo mejor está por venir
tienen grandes sueños y trabajan
incansablemente hasta lograrlos
así que en esta oportunidad quiero
compartirles
quiero compartirles acerca de lo que
estos jóvenes son capaces de realizar y
en este sentido tengo dos ejemplos uno
el de boyens lado holandés de 23 años
que diseñó el sistema de ocio inclinó
con el propósito de limpiar 5 billones
de objetos plásticos que están
contaminando el océano pacífico
otro ejemplo más cercano es el
sampedrano kevin dubón con su proyecto a
mí no a mí no es una aplicación de
inteligencia artificial que ayuda a los
médicos a identificar con mayor
exactitud las probabilidades de cáncer
en los pacientes díganme si en realidad
no son jóvenes dignos de admirar
son colaborativos e inclusivos y en esto
se diferencian mucho de nosotras las
generaciones anteriores no discriminan
ni marginan a nadie alrededor de la
ciudad del país o alrededor del mundo
están organizados en diferentes grupos
donde todos o cualquier persona es
incluida el único requisito es tener la
pasión y la voluntad de desarrollar un
proyecto creativo que pueda resolver una
problemática de nuestra sociedad y así
que así lo vemos ellos no discriminan
por temas de raza ni de color de piel ni
de eso
ni él ni del nivel socioeconómico ni del
nivel académico ni de ningún otro tipo
todos son incluidos
son colaborativos inclusivos y también
otra de sus grandes características
es que siempre
tenemos algunos problemas terminales
aun teniendo esta característica que
hemos podido ver a lo largo de estos 8
años la revista time lo describe como
impacientes inconstante inmaduros y con
poca tolerancia a la incomodidad sin
embargo yo les puedo decir que he visto
todo lo contrario y que segura de ese
gran potencial que ellos tienen me ha
dado la responsabilidad de poder
contribuir a su desarrollo personal y
profesional como lo haría como espero
como los propios hijos
así que ha desarrollado algunas
estrategias uno escucharlos activamente
en esta época de tanta cantidad de
información y de distracción que tenemos
es importante poder buscar los espacios
para poder compartir con ellos
otra de las estrategias también
trabajar en equipos de networking
multigeneracional no únicamente en temas
de multidisciplinarios sino que cada vez
que tenemos en la universidad un nuevo
proyecto o que tenemos un proceso que
debamos mejorar los llamamos a los
diferentes públicos para poder compartir
con ellos y recibir la retroalimentación
que tienen para datos compartir con
ellos en eventos también es algo muy
importante y quizás lo que más disfruto
hacer
así que de alguna manera siento una
responsabilidad de poder apoyarlos y
ayudarlos a hacer
de la universidad del espacio de trabajo
o del hogar un lugar para incubar el
mejor proyecto de vida donde se conjugan
no solamente sus habilidades sino que
también todo aquello que les apasiona y
así puedan llegar a ser adultos
realizados productivos y satisfechos
y esto me llama a una reflexión y es el
método blender blended es un proceso de
enseñanza-aprendizaje que conocemos en
educación y que se decide como el
intercambio que se da entre dos espacios
uno virtual virtual o tecnológico y otro
presencial y que este sentido en la era
de hoy en que estamos debemos vivir y
desenvolvernos de manera violenta
entendiéndolo como una oportunidad para
generar intercambio de experiencias
y fomentar el networking y el
enriquecimiento y también para
convertirse en socios estratégicos y
sobre todo para reinventarnos
constantemente
y cuando hablamos de reinventarnos
aquí tengo una historia bien importante
y es que hace dos años
mi hijo se lo invitó a correr una media
maratón con él cuando le pregunté y
porque no sé cómo creía él cuando el
deporte realmente no es mucha de mi
característica pero me busco es en sus
palabras solo te ves que vas a ganar y
empezar
[Música]
así que de esa manera
baje la app y bien obediente y empecé a
entrenar durante seis meses levantando
me tres veces por semana a las 4 15 de
la mañana para cumplir con éste
challenge' al que me había invitado mi
hijo
finalmente el 20 de mayo del año 2017
que corrimos durante dos horas y
cincuenta minutos y cruzamos la meta
agarrados de la mano mi mayor regalo no
fue la medalla no fue haber llegado a la
meta no fue haber corrido 22 kilómetros
durante 2 horas 50 minutos fue el post
que él puso en su cuenta de instar
diciendo frutales durante los últimos 25
años mi mamá me ha ayudado a alcanzar
cada una de mis metas finalmente yo fui
capaz de ayudarla a ella a alcanzar una
de las suyas
así que ese es el intercambio entre dos
generaciones no hay sueños inalcanzables
ni metas imposibles y sobre todo
disfrutamos el proceso de una manera
increíble
así que a partir de todas estas
experiencias he podido reconocer que
estos jóvenes no solamente son de
realidad aumentada sino que son
realmente de humanidad ambientada y
tienen mucho que dar a la sociedad así
que si aún no estamos preguntando cómo
vivir en sinergia con los millennials
llámese tus hijos tus colaboradores o
tus compañeros lo resumo en una sola
frase no les des instrucciones a los
millennials
dales un propósito y serán capaces de
transformar al mundo muchas gracias